for the first time here on the Rich
Eisen show a man with many titles
founder an executive chairman of
fanatics a partner of the Sixers and New
Jersey Devils co-chair of the reform
Alliance just three of the many titles
held by Michael Rubin here on the Rich
Eisen show good to see you sir good to
be here it's a lot of titles by the
Hangout have a little bit of fun I know
I just but I try to give proper
introductions well thank you you got it
um how did you get how did fnatic start
how did that whole start with you and
brother you know sometimes you just get
a little bit lucky I start in the
e-commerce business and late 90s and we
were in the Sporting Goods business we
worked with retailers like Dick's
Sporting Goods the Sports Authority
right and they sold a lot of licensed
sports parts and dice and so we started
carrying merchandise from the NFL and
the NBA and what we realized was that
there are so many fans that lived in
different markets from the team that
they were a fan of and they couldn't
find that merchandise sure and so
licensed sports for osted great all the
way back from 1998 1999 and then we
started working with the different
sports leagues and between 2000 to 2007
the NFL the NBA Major League Baseball
NHL gave us really their e-commerce
rights to operate we've built that into
a pretty big business I bought the
company back from eBay in 2011 it was a
little bit less than a 250 million our
company the previous year and now fin
acts will be over three billion dollars
in revenue next year and is growing very
quickly so how did it start like
literally you woke up one day you and
put some buddies or something great
story how it started was I knew nothing
about e-commerce I mean nothing I was
like an early entrepreneur that sold
footwear and someone called me on Black
Friday in 1998 and said what are you
doing about this internet thing I'm like
a screw the Internet it's all it's these
young kids they just know how to drive
revenue they don't they don't actually
know how to make money I don't want any
part of it and I hung up on the guy and
he called me back like a few hours later
he's like Michael you should really
think about this this e-commerce thing
right I didn't want to think about it
but then I started thinking about I did
what any entrepreneur we do I called the
owners of the biggest sporting goods
retailers like Dick's Sporting Goods and
the Sports Authority at that point and
Modell sporting goods means just cold
call them like well I was in business
with them carry my old company because I
bought and sold different athletic
footwear closeouts and Sharansky closed
out so I knew all these retailers
I said hey what do you do about this
ecommerce thing and everyone said the
same thing to me they said look we don't
really understand ecommerce
when our board of directors or asked us
lots of questions and you know if you
have any ideas please bring interest
crews you're young and maybe you can
figure it out so in 1998 I reinvented my
company I got five at the top 10 largest
sporting goods retailers to give me
their e-commerce rights over a long
period of time to run their e-commerce
business and that's how we started and I
knew nothing I just started hiring
people raising capital and I figured it
out in that company we built GSI
commerce got sold to eBay in 2011 for
2.4 billion dollars so what was the
conversation with eBay when you went in
to say I want I'm buying it back or one
of my well you know what eBay bought
from us was the overall business which
was the biggest really partner to big
retailers and brands to run their
e-commerce business and they didn't they
didn't want to be in the licensed ports
business or own inventory so when they
bought our company in 2011 they bought
it because they want to partner with
Ralph Lauren and Estee Lauder and Toys R
Us to have those big retailers work in
the eBay marketplace right and they came
to us right away and said hey we don't
want to own this business because it
owns him into it would you like to buy
it back and I was a huge believer in
what the sports licensed business could
be and I really thought we were just
getting started and to be honest I had a
lot of ideas about how we could
completely reinvent the model in 2011 so
the business that we bought in 2011
fanatics is nothing really to what it is
today we've completely reinvented the
model so what's the what's the one item
that you think sells the best in any of
the sports across jerseys without
question period yeah and you know and
today you know what it is it's a new
quarterback in in New York City he was
out selling every player on our platform
darn 'old Jones Jones Daniel Jones
number one selling jersey yes because
yesterday yes because because he was
that's a story that's what you know the
great thing about our business is
there's always change and you know
somebody does great somebody else gets
hurt new player emerges team gets cold
team gets hot and that's the change that
makes our business so unique and White's
tailor-made for the internet because
we've built a supply chain that can
always have with the fan wats at any
time and would you have ever thought a
week ago he'd be the number one selling
Jerry's you know for me know about I
would have thought about so I write
about this morning so but we put on its
high a platform to have a complete
supply chain that makes sure that
whatever a fan wants colourway team men
woman's kids whatever you want we have
millions different products and we have
a supply chain of the kind of
manufacturers on demand
that allows us to really satisfy
whatever sports fan wants so do you get
a michael rubin of again fanatics and
the Sixers in the devil's reformer
alliance right here on the Rich Eisen
show do you get inundated with calls
when Antonio Browns Raiders Jersey never
gets used in a game everything so
absolutely and we actually have a policy
where we have policies to really like in
the NBA we have an insurance policy with
American Express where if your player
gets traded or waived you can actually
get in new jersey is that right yeah
it's actually a great idea that American
Express came up with that we do
specifically for the NBA and and I'll
tell you what there's a lot of movement
in sports so you know if you think about
the NBA's roster this year and how much
movement the free agency movement there
was right on that certainly drives
tremendous choice just last year was all
about LeBron James driving jersey sales
this year think about go on there's so
many from Kawhi the Kevin Durant
Kyrie I mean there's tremendous movement
that and in all of our businesses
certainly the NFL bigger than any that
drives the business let me get a little
bit into the Sixers with you then were
you in on the Kauai front at all I don't
you know I really leave that to Elton
Brand to talk about and my partner Josh
Harrison and David played sir
what what I could tell you is you know
we I think the the organization's done a
great job putting a really high quality
team on the floor and I think we're
really optimistic about on this season
obviously you don't know where you are
until June people walk up to me every
day and say hey Michael how you feeling
about the year and I say I'll tell you
in June because if you don't have a
trophy to show at the end of the year
you haven't done what you set out to do
right well I mean to put you in a
position where if you said yes you
denigrate who you have on the team I
mean Kawhi Leonard is is look Kawhi
Leonard anyway he's an incredible player
and I think if you would have asked 30
teams that if they want a Kawhi Leonard
I think 30 teams would have told you
told you yes sure I see what you're
saying okay so with with the Sixers and
we're where this team is right now how
far do you think they can go look I
think the organization I think the
players I think people are really
optimistic about where we are I mean
last year I think for decades we're
going to remember that the for bouncing
ball that ended our series against
Toronto but I think I think we're very
optimistic I think we've got an
incredible team that's actually got
really good chemistry and is gelling to
and I think again you know my you know
I've got you know tremendous confidence
now and Brandon put the team together
and I think but you know I think we just
getting started I think we've had a
young team and one that can do
incredible things together do you
completely delegate to Alton I mean how
much is you so the way our organization
works the team that the primary owners
are Josh Harris and David Blitzer on the
third largest donor it's really I always
say it's Josh and David show to run
brands GM and I think Josh and David
really delegate to Ellen for everything
other than big decisions in any business
whether it's fanatics whether it's the
Sixers whether it's the reformed
Alliance big decisions you know keep
people involved with those and that's
the way any good organizations run so
what if you could change a rule in the
NBA you could pull a commissioner silver
or them many of your fellow partners
aside and say look let's get this done
together what would that be yeah that's
that's a great question I don't want to
think I want to speak on be I mean I was
actually thinking that all free agency
should come to the Sixers would be nice
I mean just you personally I mean that
you think that you know hey this is
something that I think should change
whether it's something on the court I
think there's a lot of talk about how
free agency works and when the windows
open and you know rules around tampering
and things like that my guess is that
you know I know the commissioners
looking at that today so I won't be
surprised if they were you know it
wouldn't surprise me if there were you
know enhancements going forward and that
you know make sure they keep improving
and one thing I can tell you about Adam
who I have a tremendous relationship
with is you know he's always looking at
how to anything doesn't make sense how
do I make it better you know certainly
going through everything that we went
through and certainly we want to build a
championship team I think different
sports are doing with you know what's
going on in Miami right now what you
know certainly people wanted to go
through rebuilds and what's the right
you know a lottery system for that so
but I think in general if I just say
there's one area that it seems like
there's some focus coming around right
now it's probably how the free to window
works and so yeah it cuz it just from a
fans point of view - it's really
confusing draft night it is way with you
with your business - I imagine - the
number of hats that go on the heads of
people who are never gonna play for that
team and it's so confusing well we start
again for a fanatics is gone from 200
company won a bar in 2011 and we're the
three billion dollar company next year
the biggest thing that drives fanatics
yes is really the consistent change in
evolution that happens in sports and
we're always taking every moment that
happens sports and figure out how to
turn that into a merchandising moment so
when something changes on drafting you
think someone's going to another team
then they go to another team that's our
business we've again we put this whole
supply chain that's made to capitalize
on the change in sports that happens
every day but I think you're the great
thing about our business and I say the
great thing about any sport um there's
always so much change to continue to
improve it it's not like I don't look at
our business and be like wow you know
we're twelve times the size when I
bought the company so we've done well
I'm like hey we just can't start in how
do we keep making it better and I say
it's the same thing in sports I think if
you asked Roger you - Adam silver they
would look at their sports and say how
do we keep improving the sport and
that's the great thing about what we do
yeah Michael Rubin here on the Rich
Eisen show fanatics founder executive
chairman and also partner the Sixers and
the devils do you go on vacation with
embiid is that true I've spent a lot of
time at you all I've spent a lot of time
with Joe I look I have a great
relationship draw have a great
relationship with Ben and and you know
based on growing up in the sports
business my entire life I've been around
you know people that make sports so it's
for me it's kind of just the way I've
grown up you got a good story for embiid
I mean well I mean do all you could have
a good struggling this there's a good
story every day right yeah per day I
probably my best Joel embiid vacation
story was we were in the Bahamas
together for a friend's birthday last
Memorial Day and Joelle decided that he
want to go down a waterslide and you
know he said we got to the top of we
were at the Atlantis and we got to the
top of the leap of faith' slide oh my
god and you all decides that he won't go
down so knowing that I was conflicted
between being one of the partners the
Philadelphia Sixers but also Joe's poor
I decide to to gravitate to being joe's
boy so I got everyone upstairs chanting
like you can do this Joe you can do this
Joey literally he gets in and he decides
he's gonna get out he gets scary it's
not gonna go down the slide so everyone
Hayes's and we get finally gets back in
and he goes down the slide and then we
can see any made I was very proud of him
his big moment I thought he was he then
proceeded to in the in the lazy river
yes to start somebody that wasn't me no
skipped his raft and he starts to
drowned I'm a joke Stan Joe stand that
word is two feet tall and Joe's
in the water and this really happened I
actually think I put some video on my
social media which of course I took a
lot of crap for doing but watching
Joelle and now even I just watching him
try to swim is one of the most comical
things you could possibly say yeah yeah
this is enough the standing should just
kneel if it's just two feet of water he
just could just get on his knees yes and
I should have screamed kneel but it's
just like seem logical and he was
literally like choking on the ward oh my
god it was it was pretty unbelievable
Wow
I just I just love everything about him
I just love his essence I love his
energy his game you know obviously when
he did the flying he got some grief for
it but everybody gives grief for get
grief for pure joy pure joy is what we
need in sports fun every day I tell you
Joe has a lot of fun and everything he
does every day Ben has fun and what he
does everything every day and that's one
of the great things these are really
mature guys that are you know both
they're great players on the court
they're also it's it's fun for me to
watch them becoming you know turn into
business people one of the things going
interesting for me is how many of the
world's best athletes call want to talk
about what they want to do in their
business careers and and how people are
at the best of their game whether it's
on the court or on the field but they're
also thinking about how can they go out
and build an incredible you know
business career for them as well and I
love seeing that well I mean it seems to
be honest and as you know I'm an NFL guy
through and through I love the sport I I
really have loved the last 16 years and
can't wait for more it seems the NBA is
a little bit more out on the forefront
on that I mean Odell wears a watch
people go nuts even though it's in the
game I mean let it go crazy but he's
trying to build a brawl hits me up often
for information about business stuff and
I love that so here's no dull side hey
Michael can you tell me about this you
know can you tell me about you know how
am i doing in Jersey sales or what
happens if I do this like he's thinking
like a business person first and he
wants to build his brand and his career
in addition everything he does on the
field right and I think that's
incredible I see that I can't tell you
how many you know NFL you know Willie
you know top play you know top stars
have hit me up via social media because
they just want they want to talk about
business they have ideas they wonder
figure out how to invest their money
I think that's changed a lot in the past
20 years I think with social media today
players are so much more advanced than
know how to market themselves better and
its really becoming a big benefit to how
they can build their business because
especially in the NFL the average length
of a career is four years it's not so
different in basketball but these guys
have to have incredible marketing
platforms you look at Odell Beckham's
platform look at your own beauty Ben
Simmons platform look at LeBrons
platform I mean these are incredible
platforms where they can they can build
real businesses from then I've said this
consistently when you look at people
like Kylie Jenner's in our early 20s has
built this billion-dollar cosmetics
brand I think the next generation of
athletes gonna build massive businesses
using their own social meeting
direct-to-consumer capabilities and I
think that's really exciting so how
should ownership and handle that how
should partnership hang yeah look from
my perspective I kind of you know I'm
kind of reactive to people that you know
kind of want help and I'm just you know
look to me the world small and people
help me all the time so I always want to
help people and you know I think a lot
of people know my story I barely made
out of high school I didn't go to
college I've always been a sponge to
smart people and so I try to you know
have smart people around me that I can
learn from and then I think people we do
that with each other and I but I learned
from all the people around me and I
think they learned from me as well so
I'm always asking questions and I think
if you ask a lot of questions get the
right people around you can generally
create good opportunities all right few
more minutes left with you Michael Rubin
again you're a Philly guy fanatics
founder as I mentioned partner with the
Sixers you do have a stake in the
devil's as well how did you meet Meek
Mill how did you first come across me
yes so Mike was really random it's my
daughter's grown up in the sports and
entertainment business and she's really
she really doesn't get excited about
anything but she was at a stage when she
was I guess seven or eight years old and
we were sitting at the NBA all-star game
and she starts grabbing my hand and she
was like dad dad I'm like what's up
she's like that's Nicki Minaj I'm like I
didn't really even know who Nicki Minaj
was that was mixed fiance at that point
and they were randomly sitting next to
us on the court so it was Nicki and meek
and myself and my daughter and so my
daughter proceeded to aggressively have
conversations with Nicki which she
normally would never do and so we can
start talking and he's like oh you know
your that you're the Sixers you know I
know you for the Sixers from Philly and
I said hey what do you do and he just
meets already asking me tons of
questions it was honestly reminded me of
a different version of myself because
I'm always asking questions and learning
and meek was immediately asking me lots
of questions about well if I want to do
this you know how would I do it and you
know I want to build this in business
you know who would I need to do it with
and so we met I guess probably six years
ago now and we became you know pretty
friendly pretty quickly where he was
coming our games all the time he was
coming out with me and my boy is we were
you know doing different trips together
and the first three or four of our years
of our relationship was purely based on
you know guys having fun together there
was absolutely nothing more than that
and then I guess like you would for any
good friend MOOC was going through this
crazy system with a criminal crazy
situation with a criminal justice system
and to be honest you know in the
beginning kind of went in one ear and
out in another ear for me because you
hear so many people's problems is you've
tried not to engage but them and then
meek was always in Philadelphia and I
would make fun of him be like yo bro
why are you in Philadelphia like you
want a job at fanatics like do you want
to I said you want to be a ball boy at
the Sixers I just like I would just mess
with him because that's what sitting no
difference then Joel Ben would mess with
me I mess with them just playing with
them anybody Michael you don't
understand like I'm on probation I can't
leave Philadelphia and that's when it
finally hit me and this was like some of
2017 I start trying to help him to get
off of probation I realized that
everything he'd ever said to me it was
all now starting to add up
was true that he had this crazy judge he
was in this crazy situation and meek
always said to me from the first time I
met him Michael if I pointed a gun at
multiple police officers that's called
suicide a black kid does not point a gun
at multiple police officers they don't
say sir can you put your gun down
they're trained to shoot and kill and he
told me that from the day I met him on
the basketball court you know when my
daughter was sitting next to Nicky in
2000 whatever was 14 or something like
that so um fast forward he said to me
the day of his probation hearing can you
come to court with me because I want you
to see this I never thought anything
about I'm like look you know I said to
my office can I move things around I
went with them and that changed my life
watching a probation officer get up and
say hey meek Millz and everything we've
asked we recommend no sentence the DA
say exactly the same thing and then a
judge say you're going to prison for two
to four years for not committing a crime
that like shook me to my core and having
one of your really good friends go to
prison for not committing a crime like I
started crying I looked at him I said
I'm
to stop until I get you out of here he
looked at me he had tears coming out of
his eyes unfortunate I was sitting next
to this woman desert Perez who's jay-z's
partner and right hand she said I'm not
stopping the two of us were basically
unrelenting until we kind of got the
situation fixed how did Robert Kraft
controls so Roberts you know I think why
they know Roberts one of my best friends
you know I talked to Robert you know
multiple times day every day
Robert had met meek through me and you
know Robert actually been on vacation
with me and I had been on a couple of
boisterous we went to the Austral game
for a major league baseball couple years
earlier and Robert in the beginning
would say to me like you know he I was
spending so much time on this he's like
Michael you're spending so much time
when this it was kind of like he didn't
he understood the importance and he
really liked meek but I'm not sure he
fully got it and then Robert said to me
we were we were in Turks and Caicos
together and Robert said to me we could
call because he would call from prison
every day and I said hey Robert you just
talk talk to me because Robert always
like to talk to him and him a little bit
inspiration and we hung up the phone
Robin said I wanted to see him right
when we land so we land in Philadelphia
it the next day we went to prison to see
meek and that was for Robert I think a
life-changing moment Robert went there
and Mika's smiling from ear to ear and I
remember Robert saying to meek like me I
don't get it
how are you so happy you're sitting here
in prison you've been here five months
you didn't commit a crime
you've told me this is the fourth time
you've been sent to prison for not
committing a crime like what like how
you I'd be so mad and meek looked up he
said Robert he said this the first time
people are fighting for me he said this
is my life this'll only think I'm used
to I've been sent to prison four times
were never committed a crime and Robert
left there and he must have called me
ten times that night it went from saying
like look he kind of just you know
interesting to how much time I'm
spending on this thing to like Michael
why have you not got him out of prison
so far like how is he not out of prison
so far I'll tell you something I tell
Robert this all the time there was no
bigger moment for Meeks situation for
the five-and-a-half months he was in
prison than when Robert Kraft you know a
rich white billionaire gets up and
speaks on Meeks behalf that went
everywhere in the world and when Robert
said this wasn't right um he got out of
prison you know he I'm not saying the
two are related but he got out of prison
a week later so and they've become there
are really good friends down they were
friendly before this happened then
and then Robert saw this injustice and
he couldn't tolerate it say it was the
same as me except for he wasn't a court
with me the first day it happened he
wasn't you know meek wasn't one of his
best friends up front to just have that
that that out-of-body reaction that I
had so I mean we could talk about this
for an hour but in the couple of minutes
we unfortunately have left how you're
the co-chair of their reform alliance
jay-z involved obviously Robert Kraft we
all hear the news what's going on with
the NFL how real is this people might be
hearing this conversation it's great
that some Meek Mill was helped but
obviously there's many people of color
who need assistance and attention being
brought to this how real is this
alliance with the NFL there's two
separate things as one of the reformer
lines that I start together a meek
Robert and jay-z that's separate of what
what Jays doing with about front let me
talk about the reform alliance because
that's something I could speak about
firsthand sure the biggest thing that
surprised me so I'm a fighter I'm gonna
entrepreneur my whole life all I've done
this like fight to get to wherever I am
and that's the way I was will things to
happen so when week was in prison um the
first thing we did was we hired multiple
different investigators to go back and
investigate the judge her cases the
police and what we learned very quickly
a cop came forward one of the two
arresting officers and said oh no he
didn't point the gun the whole thing's a
lie
we're like what this happened actually
Superbowl 2018 so I'm at the Superbowl
I'm in Minneapolis freezing my butt off
yeah Patriots are playing the Eagles
most Awkward game in the world for me
because Eagle you know maybe to my guy
before the team I grew up with right and
and literally I found out everything
because ever told me a police officer
came former validated I called Meek I
said yo bro I got great news you're
getting out of prison right away meets
like this is amazing we got a cop to
sign the affidavit saying you didn't
actually point the gun the whole rest
was a lie which is what Mike always told
me um it took another three months to
get him out of prison after the cop came
forward and said the whole thing was a
lie and that's when my conversation with
meek shifted from not how do we get you
out of prison but as soon as you got out
of prison how do we do something to help
the millions of people that stuck in the
system sometimes things just happen for
a reason I said this to make all the
time while it sucks that he's been sent
to prison four times were never
committed in a crime there are six point
seven million people in the system today
four and a half million of those people
on probation and parole and that's the
part of the system that really nobody
was focused on
so the reformer lights that I start
together with meek jay-z Robert Dan Loeb
Clara sie several apartments Mike
Novogratz Laura Arnold we've dedicated
more than 50 million hours of our own
money we haven't brought in a bit it's
all of our own money to basically change
the probation and parole law so we're
focused on doing two things one changing
the laws on a state-by-state basis and
to really getting the message out there
from a marketing perspective and take
Pennsylvania where I'm from or where
Meeks from this will blow your mind away
there's no cap on probation so I tell me
all the time I think he's got the
Guinness Book of World Record for
longest probation ever given to somebody
he was charged for committing a crime I
didn't commit when he was 18 at 31 he'd
been on probation for 12 years and had
another six years left
because in Pennsylvania there's no cap
on probation so me could literally not
meek did a concert outside of
Philadelphia he ain't got sent to prison
for 90 days for doing that concert so
laws are broken so what we want to do is
stop people from being sent to prison
for not committing crimes 175,000 people
year go to prison for technical
violations they didn't commit a crime a
quarter the people so that's what we're
about at the reform Alliance and you
could learn more through your social
media feeds at Michael G Ruben on
Twitter at Michael Rubin on Instagram
thanks for coming on hopefully its first
of many brought a lot of friends in
common so I'm glad we finally got to it
we got a big race we hope is coming up
yeah that's right we're for a st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital we're gonna
talk about that I'll talk about that on
Friday show as a matter of fact but good
to see you thank you for being a thanks
have you got it for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app